зараз у нас на зв'язку Сергій шкарлет
Міністр освіти і науки України пане
Сергію Вітаю
вас пане Володимире в Україні Героям
слава пане Сергію я почну з не зовсім
приємної звичайно для вашого
Міністерства події оцей вибух ракети на
перехресті Володимирської і
бульвару Шевченка у Києві серйозно
пошкодив одне з найголовніших приміщень
вашого Міністерства і вибухова хвиля
якраз пішла в основному на нього можете
детальніше розказати наскільки серйозні
руйнування цього будинку
Дуже дякую за запитання адже доносили
доношу До цього світу до своїх колег
міністрів з країни Європейського Союзу
до світових колег що саме Російська
Федерація здійснює удари
по цивільних об'єктах і зокрема
руйнування дісталося будинку
Міністерства освіти і науки Київського
національного університету Шевченка
Київського фахового коледжу
зв'язку в них президент
Шевченківський парк у нас зазнав ви
знаєте акцент
р вибуховався саме на ту будівлю яка
обслуговувала
проблеми освіти і науки новації
профтехосвіти цифровізації саме саме ці
підрозділи знаходились там в нас на в
цій будівлі немає сьогодні жодного
непошкодженого кабінету але знаєте що
символично
я зайшов туди в конференц-залі
залишився стояти прапор України і банер
Міністерства освіти і науки було знищено
майже все але прапор і банер стояли і це
в цьому я побачив певний символізм
завжди стояли стоїть на сторожі держави
інтересів які пріоритетів які ставить
президенту України прем'єр-міністр
України ми вистояємо ми сильні ми
Україна пан міністр згадали що крім
вашого приміщення постраждали там же ж
поруч так і університет Шевченка два
корпуси червоної жовтий і коледж зв'язку
який теж неподалік Чи є можливість
оперативно їх відремонтувати чи бодай
привести у стан який буде придатний для
подальшого навчання
А ви знаєте на сьогодні чим ми
займаємось всі разом Ми сьогодні
закриваємо і пошкоджені вікна вхідну
групу для того щоб по-перше
убезпечити плісняву сирість волога Ну ми
розуміємо що верхнє поверхи завжди
можуть її поселення птиць там бути і все
інше ми маємо уберегти всіх приміщення
ми маємо уберегти наші і кабінети і
університети було коледжу але постраждав
не тільки коледж постраждав не тільки
університет тільки по місту Києву три
школи один садочок два позашкільних
закла і Бог по Україні під час 10-го
жовтня постраждало 38 закладів освіти Що
сьогодні робиться ми терміново формуємо
терміново сформувати певну суму коштів
яка дала можливість освітлення закриття
вхідної групи і ремонту даху для
попередження холодів для упередження
заливання для підготовки до осіння
зимового періо
зрозуміло це стосовно цих навчальних
закладів Але після понеділкового удару
також було ухвалене рішення перевести на
дистанційну форму навчання всі школи
наскільки це можливо і тут хочеться
зрозуміти станом на сьогодні є у вас
розуміння чи буде продовжене це рішення
Міністерства Чи можливо з понеділка ви
дозволите і очну форму
я дякую вам хочу трошки поправити адже
Міністерство ні в якому разі не ухвалює
рішення рекомендує щодо формування
освітнього процесу і форми організації
освітнього процесу враховуючи суспільну
небезпеку а від ударів Російської
Федерації ракетних ударів бомбових
ударів я завжди казав безпека на
області тому сам Міністерство зробило
перший наголос і рекомендувало перевести
до п'ятниці в онлайн формат навчання
адже і батьки і діти і вчителі Ну звісно
це не ми вже звикаємо до війни але при
цьому безпека на першому місці ми маємо
убезпечити всіх учасників освітнього
процесу остаточне рішення приймається
керівником військової адміністрації
засновником або керівником громади щодо
кожного закладу освіти і формування його
індивідуальної освітньої траєкторії це
очна змішана або
або
повноформатне навчання я абсолютно
впевнений що безпекова безпекова
ситуація по наявності сховищ по
забезпеченні вкладу держави у формуванні
безпечного освіт
70% закладів освіти принаймні змішане
навчання запровадити тобто з хоча б з
якоюсь долею соціаліза
ції спілкування учнів і вчителів
студентів і професорів доцентів адже це
є запорукою Які
сних залишкових
так безперечно Тобто ви рекомендували я
просто не зовсім коректно висловився
тобто наскільки я зрозумів Ви готові З
понеділка рекомендувати
переходити на таку змішану форму
навчання тим більше Наскільки я розумію
бомбосховище у школах ми з вами якось
кілька тижнів тому про це говорили вони
зроблені за певними вимогами і вони дуже
часто безпечніші ніж якщо діти
залишаються просто вдома ви абсолютно
праві адже бобосховище атестовані за
стандартами державної служби
надзвичайної ситуації і ми сьогодні
спілкуємось із батьками із вчителями
розраховуючи на те що наприклад дитина
яка знаходиться на сьомому на третьому
на сьомому на 11-му поверсі іноді іноді
більш небезпечному стано три повітряний
тривозі ніж
знаходять освіти атестованому комісію в
яку входили державна служба надзвичай
них маючи різного типу укриття і маючи
кваліфікований персонал який здатний
абсолютно повністю забезпечити безпеку
всіх
учасників супроводити дитину до сховища
надати їй водичку дати можливість
займатися цій дитинці
відповідно до профілю того чим або
іншого класу проводити там групу
продовженого дня Я особисто був
декільках закладах так само і при
повітряній тривозі і бачив як
це на сьогодні 70% закладів освіти
забезпечено такими укриттям
це хороша цифра
але тепер постає питання стосовно
наступного бюджетного року чи зможе ваше
Міністерство ну принаймні не гірше ніж
цього року забезпечувати
оцей освітній процес тому що попередній
аналіз який робили освітяни проекту
бюджету на наступний рік він вказує на
те що там приблизно на 17% передбачають
скоростити фінансування освіти як ви
реагуєте як міністр на такі скорочення
знаєте будь-які скорочення бюджету
Міністерства для профільного міністра є
як би Вольт болючою процедурою але ми
маємо всі розуміти Сьогодні ми живемо
військовий стан сьогодні майбутнє
України залежить від нашої
обороноздатності якщо адже якщо не буде
нашої Перемоги якщо ми не вистаємо в цій
боротьбі То тоді в принципі і
забезпечення всіх інших видатків
виглядає трошки сумнівним хочу сказати
що декілька секвестрів саме 22-го року
видатки Міністерства освіти також були
зменшені і на цей рік але ми спромоглися
разом з керівниками департаментів
засновниками закладів освіти в цілому з
освітянами сформувати освітній процес
Таким чином та економно над ефективною
раціонального використання цих коштів
щоб завершити цей освітній рік ми також
чітко розуміємо що в наступному році Так
є певне скорочення на 17%. але
я чітко розумію чітко знаю позицію уряду
України президента України що при певній
можливості збільшення видатків і
переконання державного бюджету на
наступний рік Витрати
нас будуть безумовно скореговані на
користь освітян
тоді ще одне уточнення з цього приводу
чи передбачені будуть гроші на
друкування підручників чи достатньо їх
буде бо цього року ми знаємо є проблеми
навіть
скорочення видатків державного бюджету
18% ми в цьому році маємо дві нові
субвенції перше що це є забезпечення
безпечних умов для закладів освіти в
розмірі 1,5 млрд це і сховища І взагалі
безпекова ситуація а також придбання
шкільних автобусів на мільярд грн та
Так ми маємо сьогодні проблеми щодо
забезпечення коштами видатків
на завдячуючи на
шим дортнерам Європейському Союзу іншим
нашим донором ми намагаємось утримувати
ситуацію щодо підручників на досить
досить
в нормальному стабільному стані
наприклад на сьогодні більше ніж 1300
примірників підручників розміщено в
електронному форматі має вірш у вільному
доступі всі новітні примірники на 22-23
навчальний рік а і на наступний рік ми
маємо так при потребі півтора мільярда
ми маємо половину цих коштів але я чітко
знаю що ми сьогодні стукаємо у всі двері
донорів і сьогодні видатки на друк нових
підручників для учнів шостого класу в
нас передбачені У проекті Закону України
Про Державний бюджет все інше ми
вирішуємо з донорами з видавництвами і
сьогодні всі українці всі закордонні
партнери підтримують нас в цьому без
підручників діти не залишаться в
будь-якому форматі
формат або в електронному
залишається але я хотів ще одне
запитання якщо можна коротку відповідь з
приводу планів про переведення на
бюджетну форму навчання тих студентів
які поступили в українські вищі з
тимчасово окупованих територіях
наскільки це реалістично реалістично
Дуже дякую за запитання адже це питання
було і
ніцію у відповідне доручення на сьогодні
я сподіваюсь що ми найближчим часом
винесемо це на засідання уряду але це не
закупованих територій це так званих
небезпечних території які по наказу
мінреінтеграції формується ті громади
які були неокуковані яких ведуться
активні бойові дії які окуповані ми
маємо дбати про своїх громадян які на
сьогодні опинилися в скрутному становищі
це доручення президента ми його
виконаємо безперечно Дякую дуже пане
міністри за те що знайшли час відповісти
на запитання Сергій шкарлет Міністр
освіти і науки України був з нами в
ефірі марафон у єдині новини